le secrétaire général a fermement condamné la
mutinerie militaire qui a abouti à l'
arrestation
du président uh keita et des membres de son
gouvernement
le secrétaire général appelle à un
rétablissement immédiat de l'ordre constitutionnel
et de l'état de droit au mali il réitère
son appel à une solution négociée
résolution pacifique de leur  différences
et exprime son plein soutien à l'
union africaine
cedeao dans ses efforts pour trouver une
solution pacifique à la
crise actuelle, y compris grâce aux bons
offices d'un représentant spécial,
nos collègues sur le terrain
soulignent que le travail de la
mission de maintien de la paix de l'onu
doit et sera  continuer à soutenir le
peuple malien
et en liaison étroite avec les maliens
y compris avec les forces de sécurité et de défense maliennes
dans le nord et le centre où la
situation est toujours très préoccupante